The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Welcome to Course
Design today, how to plan a
course and avoid the pitfalls
that many courses fall into.
In the past few sessions we've
seen some of the results, for
example the misconceptions,
the rote
learning, the lack of transfer.
And how do you design a course
so that your course doesn't
commit more of that and
contribute to that problem,
but instead perhaps
mitigates it?
And it's a difficult problem.
So related to that, sort of
flowing almost directly from
course design is that making
large changes to courses is
politically very difficult.
And several people have asked
me questions about that.
So actually the penultimate
session will be political
barriers to educational
change.
So for example, the Benezet
experiment, what happened to
Benezet's experiment?
Why isn't it done more?
So actually, I went to the
Manchester School Board,
Manchester, New Hampshire, and
looked at all the school board
minutes from the 1930s
to see what happened.
So I'll talk a bit about that,
talk about what are the
structural obstacles to change
so that you know what you're
up against so that you can make
strategic, sly choices
and not get yourself
shot at too much.
But that's sort of
a consequence
of good course design.
And that we'll do in the
penultimate session.
This time we'll talk about if
you had your ideal world, what
would you do?
Sort of a process of successive
approximation.
In the ideal world what
would you do?
And then in the real world,
how do you get as close to
that as you can?
So today, course design, which
is how do you design a course
so that you avoid the
main problems with
the traditional courses?
So now before I say how do you
design a course like that, let
me review a bit.
We've seen some of it in
the previous sessions.
But what are the problems with
the traditional courses?
So the problems in the
traditional courses in broad
outlines are, one,
rote learning.
I think that's the most
fundamental problem.
So we've seen many
examples of that.
And I'll just remind
you of a few.
And I'll show you a couple.
So I'll remind you
of a few just to
summarize it in one second.
And related to rote learning is
that there's no transfer.
So what are the causes?
Well, we'll come to
that in a second.
But for example, what do I
mean by rote learning?
So rote learning is the
fundamental problem.
And it actually causes
this one.
If you learn by pattern
matching, you're not going to
be able to transfer to a new
situation unless you happen to
have by luck seen that
pattern before.
But any really new situation
will be completely unfamiliar
and you won't be
able to do it.
So the examples--
so the canonical example,
because I find this actually
very helpful to have a canonical
example of what is
rote learning, I think this
is the canonical example.
It's that.
So I have that picture in my
mind and the whole story
behind that picture
is this one.
So this is from Wertheimer
again.
So students are learning to
find the area of this
parallelogram.
And they move that triangle over
there, make a rectangle.
They know how to find the
area of the rectangle.
So rote learning, you can test
for rote learning by giving
them this picture.
And the students who didn't
understand but it only seemed
like they understand, they take
the triangle and they
don't know what to do with it.
So they can't find the area
anymore, because what this
reveals is that they didn't
actually understand what they
were doing.
They didn't understand that the
purpose of this procedure
was to make a rectangle because
you know how to find
the area of a rectangle.
They thought what you do is
you chop off the left
triangle, move it over there,
and then you do
some w times h.
So operationally, it looks
almost exactly the same.
But cognitively, underneath,
what's going on under the
hood, is something completely
different, you find out, when
students have done rote
learning, because they can't
do this problem.
So this one actually has all
aspects of rote learning.
So if they can't even do this
problem, they haven't even
done any learning.
But if they can do this one but
not this one, they've done
rote learning.
OK.
So now if they haven't done
any learning, that's a
completely separate problem,
generally not
the problem we have.
We have problems with students
who have done way too much
learning, but it's all in
the wrong direction.
So that's one example.
Have I shown you folks--
probably some of you, the
Army bus problem?
The Army bus problem
is very amusing.
So there are 1,128 soldiers.
And they have to be bused from
one base to another.
So this actually, again, was
another National Assessment of
Educational Progress problem.
So it was given to
a sample of about
50,000 high school students.
So it was a huge study.
And there's 36 per bus
that you can take.
So the question is,
how many buses?
So it's not a rocket
science question.
They're just supposed to figure
out how many buses to
use and maybe one is the
right answer, maybe.
But you just keep shuttling
back and forth.
Let's assume that's not
what was looked for.
So I'll just give you this.
So 1,128 over 36
is 31 and 1/3.
So now I'm giving you that
basically to simulate the
state of mind of the students,
because it turns out about 70%
of the students did this
division correctly.
So now there's another
30% who didn't even
learn division correctly.
Let's leave those
people aside.
Of the 70%, in other words most
of them, who could do the
division correctly,
what did they say?
OK.
So take a minute.
Find a neighbor and see if you
can predict what the students
say and what the distribution
of answers is.
So this is practice
understanding where students
are coming from.
This is American high
school students.
OK.
So can someone suggest one
answer that people gave?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Actually 31
[INAUDIBLE] buses.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So that was one of
the answers.
So actually, the way that in
America at least when I was in
school you were taught to
write it as 31 R 12.
So that means 31 remainder 12,
which I think is a completely
broken way of doing things.
But that's what we learned
in school.
And that's what some fraction
of students wrote.
OK.
Another answer.
AUDIENCE: 31.
PROFESSOR: 31.
AUDIENCE: 31 because
they round off.
PROFESSOR: 31 to round off.
And another one?
AUDIENCE: 32.
PROFESSOR: 32 would be nice.
Right.
So these in fact were
the three answers.
And they were all equally
chosen, except for this was
sort of slightly preferred
to the others.
So they were all roughly
25% of--
this was, say, 75%.
These were all about 25%.
I think this was 28%.
So this one was the
winning one.
Now just stare at that
for a minute.
What does that tell you?
It tells you that-- what it
tells me is that the problem
had no meaning for
the students.
Again, they'd done learning.
So of the rite learning,
they'd done learning.
There's no question
about that.
They'd learn how to divide.
They all could divide.
But they didn't know what
the hell they'd done.
So if you wrote, oh, yeah,
if you filled out on the
requisition form for the Army
I need 31 R 12 buses, where
would you be?
You'd probably be peeling
potatoes for the
next week, on KP duty.
So this shows no meaning.
And what it shows is that for
most students, there was
actually no meaning.
Here, again this also shows
no meaning, but in a more
sophisticated way than this.
At least they thought about
what to do with the R 12.
And they came up with the
wrong answer, but they
thought about it.
And here, we'll hope they
actually understood.
So of the 100%, 30% couldn't
do the division.
Roughly another 20%,
it had no meaning.
Another 30%, no meaning.
So now we're at 80%.
And only about 20% really
understood what was going on
in a really fundamentally
simple problem.
So that is a striking example
to me of how deep the rote
learning is.
It's the same as that problem I
showed you last time, which
was 3.04 times 5.3,
I think it was.
You had to multiply.
And students had to choose--
they had to estimate it.
They didn't actually have
to do the calculation.
They had to choose between
1.6, 16, 160,
one of these four.
And it was just chance,
basically.
So again, the number
system didn't
mean anything to people.
So it's really fundamental.
It's really terrible.
And it's been studied a lot.
So the problem is not just
in American teaching.
It's across the world.
It shows up in physics.
So the physics example I
showed you was this.
So this is the bouncing ball.
So it's stationary just for an
instant while it's bouncing.
And what everyone drew
was that there was--
normal force equals
mg and there's mg.
Why?
Well, v equals zero.
So there's several reasons.
Here, partly there was rote
learning involved, because n
was always equal to mg in all
these other problems.
So they just triggered
off of that.
The other one is that there
is indeed misconception.
They actually think
f equals mv.
So that's the third.
So here, there's deep
rote learning.
There's no transfer.
What are the causes?
So there you see one
of the causes.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
[INAUDIBLE].
Couldn't it also be a problem
of multiple choice thing,
because [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: It wasn't
multiple choice.
They were just given the
problem just like this.
No.
I don't think anyone who made
a multiple choice would ever
have dreamt to put that
one on there.
AUDIENCE: Well, I mean
this is [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But I think it was phrased like
how many buses should you
order, something like that.
I mean, they should come
up with some integer.
AUDIENCE: They would write in an
answer that they would get.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
No, it was a blank, not
a multiple choice.
It was a short answer.
So that's how they could see
that they'd done the division
correctly or not.
And so all of the ones who had
done the division correctly,
this is what you got.
Another question?
No.
OK.
Question.
AUDIENCE: So I have
another question.
You've shown us many studies
that prove that there's more
rote learning going on.
And all those studies come from
the '30s and the '60s.
So why is it still
a problem today?
PROFESSOR: Oh.
So this one was '84, I
believe, '83 or '84.
And let's see, when were
some of the others?
So Wertheimer was the
'50s or the '40s.
Those examples are the '40s,
so yeah, you're right.
AUDIENCE: Why is it
still a problem?
PROFESSOR: Well, every time
I ask this one, I
get the same results.
So this I've asked between 1998
and 2009, and always got
the same results.
What are some of the others?
So another one is quel
age est le capitaine?
So that's a French study.
So they asked students--
the question was, how
do we know it's
still a problem today?
So they've asked students,
there are 26 sheep and 10
goats on a ship.
How old is the captain?
It's a good question.
The problem is the answer.
The answer is that people answer
36, because they have
to stir the numbers around
somehow and get something.
So that was done in the
'80s, I believe.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: That's not quite
what I'm asking.
I'm asking, if there is so much
evidence that supports
the existence of the problem,
why isn't it solved?
PROFESSOR: Oh.
OK.
Good question.
Sorry.
I thought your question was,
wasn't it all done long ago so
it's not a problem now.
Oh, yeah.
If there's so much evidence to
support the existence of a
problem, why isn't it solved?
So I would say there's two
parts to that answer.
One part is that, a, lots of
people don't know about this.
So normally when you teach--
so there's sort of an implicit
contract, which is that if I
don't ask you questions like
that, you won't reveal to me
that I'm not teaching you any
of these important things.
So for example, if you just take
a regular course, it's
actually possible to do
all the problems by
pattern-matching, mostly.
So as an example in physics,
you'll have--
say you're doing circular
motion.
And someone will say, well,
there's a car going around a
turn and the radius of
the turn is this.
And it's going at 30
miles an hour.
What's the force?
Or the car has a mass, m, what's
the force that the road
has to exert to keep
it in the turn?
Well, you don't have
to know anything
about circular motion.
All you have to know is that
there must be some formula
which has-- so let's
look at the
variables that I just said.
There is F is the unknown.
m is given.
v is given.
And r is given.
So you just flip through the
book until you find a formula
with all of those guys, which
happens to be F equals mv
squared over r.
And then you just plug
everything in.
So you can do all those problems
without understanding
anything about centrifugal
and centripetal.
For example, 95% of students who
can find this formula with
no problem, if you ask them,
well, can you draw me a force
diagram, 50/50 on whether the
force is outwards or inwards.
You can ask them things like,
OK, a car is accelerating.
Where does the force
come from?
Or a car is decelerating.
Where does the force
come from?
Oh, you know, the road.
That seems really strange.
But it's true.
It's in fact from the road.
So they have huge misconceptions
even about
linear forces, let alone
circular forces.
So the regular way of teaching
actually doesn't expose those.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do you think if the
standardized exams had
higher-level questions
on them.
like Bloom's Taxonomy, would
that help [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That would help, actually.
So I can say something
about how--
maybe I should've said this
last time, about how--
so the question was, if
standardized exams were better
and had higher-level questions,
would that help?
I think it would help.
And you can still even do it
multiple choice and still have
higher-level questions.
So here's actually a pretty
striking example.
Let's see if I can
remember exactly.
Oh, yeah.
So you ask students--
these are young kids, but
it applies generally.
And it's a question about
how to design tests.
So you ask them, I have a piece
of red cellophane and
blue cellophane.
And I put them together.
What color do I get?
OK.
So now the question isn't so
much what is the right answer?
But what do you think students
say when you ask them that?
And these are young kids.
So takes a minute and see if you
come up with what they say
as their answer, their
most common answer.
So you ask this as an
open-ended question.
You don't give them
multiple choice.
So talk to your neighbor
about that.
OK.
So I think it's actually very
difficult to predict what
students actually say.
And I'm willing to eat
a chalk if anyone--
well, I don't know if
I should say that.
That's a bit risky.
But let's just-- chalk
is probably safe.
But let's say I'm willing to eat
a chalk, maybe with salt
and pepper, if anyone can
actually figure out what the
students actually said, the main
thing they say, because
it's really, really
counterintuitive.
Yes?
Oh, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Reddish-blue.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So reddish-blue is one thing.
Yeah.
So that's one answer they give.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Brown.
PROFESSOR: Brown.
Yes, they probably
do say that.
AUDIENCE: Reddish-blue
is like violet?
PROFESSOR: Reddish-blue
is like violet.
Yeah.
But if they are young enough,
they might not know of the
color violet.
They might, or purple.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'll go with
saying violet-purple.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So violet-purple.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yellow.
PROFESSOR: Yellow.
I'm still safe.
So they do say all these.
I don't know about all of them
in particular, but they say
most of these things.
I'm so far safe from
my chalk wager.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Blue.
PROFESSOR: Blue.
OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Black.
PROFESSOR: Black.
That would be nice.
Yeah.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Would they say it
depends which one is on top?
PROFESSOR: Uh-oh.
I've got to eat my chalk.
Yes.
So does it matter
which one's--
yeah.
In particular, they say,
which one's on top?
Can I have salt with that?
So that is in fact the
main question.
So now why do I bring
this question up?
Well, the normal way you'd
make a multiple choice
question is you'd ask the
question yourself.
You'd think, well, what are
the plausible answers?
You'd come up with many
of the choices here.
And you'd put them down in
the multiple choice.
And you'd never think of
putting this one there.
So one way to actually design
the questions is that you
first do it with a pilot group
with a short answer.
And then you make your multiple
choices based on the
main misconceptions
that they have.
OK.
So now what's the obstacle
when you do this?
The obstacle when you do this
is you get this very funny
item response curve.
So the item response curve
is the following.
So the idea response curve
you get, so it--
OK.
So on this axis is the student's
overall grade.
And this is the--
so you have a test say, of
50 questions or whatever.
And this is their overall
grade on this axis.
On this axis is their
probability of getting one
particular question correct.
So now, a usual, a normal
question is
something like that.
If they don't know anything,
they have no chance
of getting it right.
Maybe they have some monkey
line level over here.
So let's call it something
like that.
OK.
But these kind of questions
actually have a
very different shape.
Their shape is shaped like a J.
So what happens is that--
so this is the good questions.
I think they are much
better questions.
But they get this shape.
So what happens is when the
students are just guessing,
they're somewhere down here.
But as they start to think about
it and learn more, then
they fall into the
misconceptions.
So they actually go down.
So they actually can even
be below chance.
And then only when they really
understand things
do they get up here.
So now what happens, for
example, if the SAT ever
contains a question like this,
they just throw it out.
They say, oh, this question does
not measure how good a
student we have.
It's actually skewed.
It's all messed up.
So you throw it out.
So these normal, standard ways
of making standardized tests
actually throw out all
the good questions.
And all you're left with is
these kind of questions.
So I actually saw an
example of this in
Cambridge, which was--
so you remember the rolling down
the plain question that I
showed you last week
or the week before?
So the rolling down the
plain question is
an intuitive question.
It's qualitative.
It's hard.
If you try to calculate it,
you'll get yourself in a knot
unless you know exactly
what you're doing.
But if you reason about it
intuitively, you can do it
quite well.
OK.
So that question was then put
on the end-of-year exam for
the sophomores.
And the examiner said, well,
actually this question was not
a good question, because it
didn't measure who the good
students were.
So what they meant was that
the good students actually
sometimes did worse on
that question than
the not-so-good students.
So they said, OK.
We're just going to throw
that question out.
I mean, they didn't throw
it that time.
But we're not going to use
questions like that next time.
So again, here you had a good
qualitative question.
And it didn't measure the
quote, "good" students.
So it didn't give them
what they wanted.
So they threw it out.
So if you design a test like
that, you're going to fill it
with questions that
are just sort of
low on Bloom's Taxonomy.
But it doesn't mean you have
to do that it way.
So if you want to make a test
that is higher on Bloom's
Taxonomy and tests misconception
and qualitative
reasoning and intuitive
reasoning, the way you do it
is you do a short answer
first, put the main
misconceptions down.
And you just have to be
willing to live with
this kind of curve.
AUDIENCE: But when you say you
don't evaluate the good
student, but the question is how
do you in the first place
evaluate the good students
if you have a
normal kind of system?
How do you basically
evaluate them?
PROFESSOR: How do you tell who
the good students are?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Well, it's a
reification that's going on.
I mean, there's this idea
that there's such a
thing as a good student.
And just because you call it
that doesn't mean there is
such a thing.
So you need some definitions.
So like for example,
what is IQ?
The definition is it's what
IQ tests measure.
I mean, that's the only,
I would say, valid
definition of IQ tests.
So here, good student
meant doing well on
the standard problems.
Now, I don't think
that's a good
definition of a good student.
But that is the implicit
definition in most courses.
So to answer your question, it's
the standard way things
are done, the implicit
definition that it makes it so
hard to change the rote
learning, but also so hard to
even see that it's going on.
And then the other half of
the answer is that--
and when you try to change
it, you find all
these political obstacles.
And that's what we're going
to talk about in
the penultimate session.
But for example, people
downstream.
And one question was raised
about this in the questions.
The next courses will say, well,
you didn't teach them X.
Suppose you say, oh my god.
I'm teaching them sophomore
mechanics and they don't know
Newton's three laws.
Well, I could just do oiler's
top and the herpolhodes and
the polhodes, and all of that
stuff and gyroscopes and all
this complicated stuff, which is
sort of a nonsense if they
don't understand
Newton's laws.
Or I could actually sort out
their misconceptions on
Newton's laws.
Well, suppose you take
time to do that.
Well, then they haven't
learned what
the herpolhode is.
So who knows what the
herpolhode is?
So I sort of remember
a while ago.
But even I taught the course
and I hardly remember it.
But the next downstream course
will say, they didn't know the
herpolhode because you spent
time on Newton's laws.
So that's the political
problem.
So you have to then somehow get
the people downstream to
see that this is a serious
problem, that we can only
build sand castles in the air
for so high before they
collapse because the air can't
support that much.
And that's what I'm going
to talk about in
the penultimate session.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
problem, was the purpose of
the test, because if the
purpose of the test is to
evaluate the students, you
don't want to throw in
tricky questions.
PROFESSOR: Well, so the question
is which question you
use, does it depend on the
purpose of the test?
It does.
But I think you absolutely need
these kind of questions,
or you're not actually
evaluating the right thing.
So if you only put these kind
of questions in, you're not
exposing any misconceptions.
So you're actually not
evaluating some of the
important questions about what
the students understand.
Because, for example, if you
just give them colors on this
question, you'll never realize
that that's what they're
thinking about.
So actually you're just
evaluating can they give you
one of the pre-prescribed
color answers.
But that actually doesn't
necessarily mean that they
understand.
So you're not actually
evaluating their
understanding.
So to evaluate understanding
you do need
questions like this.
And should you punish them
for being down here?
No.
That's the other part of it.
If they're down here,
that means they're
thinking about it.
So if you then grade them and
they came down here and you
say, oh, you did really
badly, no.
Actually you're down here,
that's because you're thinking
about it and you got caught
by the misconception.
But that's the only way to sort
out the misconception.
You have to go beyond it.
OK.
Other questions?
And then we'll take a break.
OK.
So it is 10:05, actually,
according to that
clock, plus an hour.
So 9:15, according
to that clock.
So 10:15, see everyone
back here.
Take a short, 10-minute break,
just as if it were two 1-hour
classes with the 10
minute break.
And then I'll put the feedback
sheets in the corners.
So when you come back,
just make sure you
grab a feedback sheet.
OK.
So before, we talked about the
problems with what most
courses do and how rote learning
is a primary product.
And as a consequence of that,
there's no transfer to new
situations.
So the knowledge is
very brittle.
So what are the causes?
And what can you do about it?
So just briefly, the causes
partly are no account is taken
of the misconceptions
students have.
So new rote learning is piled on
old misconceptions, because
by definition learning is
going to turn into rote
learning if there's no
understanding and meaning
given to it, just like
the 1,128 divided
by 36 is 31 R 12.
So no account is taken of what
students have rote learned and
what they've really understood,
because the way
the course is normally taught,
those ideas, those common
misconceptions aren't exposed
in the normal run of the way
the course happens.
And another is-- so
that's directly
related to the problem.
Another one is that the
applications are very narrow.
So because the applications in
the class are so confined to
the same area, it's very easy
to produce rote learning.
And so I have a--
I keep saying how pictures
are the way to understand
everything.
So I have a picture for that.
So I show everyone
this picture.
And if you keep this picture in
your mind, it'll give you a
guide for how you should
make problems and
what examples to choose.
So suppose there is some idea
you'd like to teach.
We'll talk in a bit about why
you'd like teach an idea at
all, but some idea you
want to teach.
And you have a clear conception
of this idea.
For example, maybe the idea is
something like DNA is the
fundamental unit of information
in living systems.
OK, well that means
something to you.
But to the students, it doesn't
actually mean anything.
You need to give
them examples.
So you're giving them
an example.
A related one is you have
some idea, which
is dimensional analysis.
And you want to give them an
example of doing it, because
just stating the Buckingham pi
theorem for them doesn't
really help them.
So you do an example.
But now picture yourself back
in the student mind.
What do the students see?
Well, they don't have this idea
as a separate unit yet,
because they're still
students.
And the purpose of the course
is to teach that.
So they haven't got yet.
So they have this merger of
idea and example together.
So they see this big package and
have trouble making that
division between idea and
example, in other words,
between transferable idea and
thing that was particular to
the situation.
So of course what do you do?
You give them another example.
So the normal way it's done is
here's your second example.
So there's the second example.
But now, again from the
student's point of view,
there's still quite a big
overlap between idea plus
example one and idea
plus example two.
So that overlap is--
if they intersect things
mentally in their head and see
what's common, they still get
a lot of stuff that's beyond
just the idea.
For example, if you do a bunch
of dimensional analysis
examples related to entropy,
then they'll think, oh,
dimensional analysis is a way
of solving entropy problems.
So here, the overlap
is too big.
So what do you have to do?
AUDIENCE: More examples.
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
PROFESSOR: More examples.
And where should they
be in this space?
Yeah, way around, right?
So you should make an
example over here.
So this example has very little
intersection with the
other example.
So here, this one and this one
and this one, they all have
very little overlap.
So now the overlap among
all three is pretty
much just the idea.
But think how different that is
from the way most courses
are designed.
Most courses, the examples,
you'll do 18 problems with the
ideal gas law.
You'll do 18 integration
by parts.
You'll do 18 solutions
of first order
differential equations.
You'll solve 18 ion
channel problems
with a Nernst equation.
All of those actually don't
teach you the fundamental idea
to be able to transfer it.
So that's another cause,
see, that the
applications are too narrow.
So you have to choose
your applications
as widely as possible.
And this makes teaching very
hard, because it means you
can't really-- yes, question?
AUDIENCE: So it can't just be
like also the structure
involved with it. it's
defined as having a
class and having problems.
So obviously, do something
in written.
But you never really
communicate that.
And if you would have like
let's say in physics, you
would have [INAUDIBLE].
And maybe you have an exam, an
oral exam where you basically
can evaluate the students and
really can find out if the
students understood
the main idea.
And then he has to
be transferred,
transfer the skills.
So I mean in terms of like
broadening the way of how you
question the students
will help basically
get the idea across.
PROFESSOR: I think
that's right.
So the suggestion was that
oral exams are actually--
in general, it's true, are a
much better way of evaluating
whether the student understands
or not.
It's very disconcerting for the
students, because, I think
I said this last time, basically
in an oral exam, as
soon as the student understands
something, you ask
something else.
So you're like, OK.
They know that.
Let me ask them about
something else.
So the student feels like
they're never talk about
something they know.
But that's the purpose of it.
So yeah, an oral exam,
like a PhD qualifying
exam, forces transfer.
That's what you're checking
for in the
PhD qualifying exam.
So if you do things like that
in the undergraduate course,
that's setting a goal of
transfer, that this is one of
the goals of the course, that
you be able to use these
skills in new situations
I'm going to ask about.
But of course, to be fair, you
have to give them practice in
doing that.
You can't just give them regular
problems and all of a
sudden give them an oral exam
where you say now transfer it
to a new thing.
They'll just hit a brick wall.
But it helps you in designing
the course.
So I'll put the backward design
diagram up again, to
show that process.
So here, you want to
choose from as
wide a set as possible.
And generally, that's
not done.
So I wanted to read a couple
of selections from the Eric
experiment about what
happens in class.
So I know you had a
choice of reading.
So who chose the Eric
experiment?
I thought they were
all fascinating.
So if you remember,
there was a couple
quotes from Eric himself.
So for those who didn't read
it, Eric was a non-physics
student who took a summer
session physics course
freshman, physics course,
and recorded--
I think he was a philosophy
major.
And he recorded his impressions
of what it was
like to be in a physics class.
So that's actually--
you get quite a different view
of what a physics class should
be when someone from outside
comes, sort of like this
diagram all over again.
He said the class consisted
basically of problem solving
and not of any interesting or
inspiring exchange of ideas.
The professor spent the first
15 minutes defining terms.
And apparently that was all the
new information we were
going to get on kinematics.
Then he spent 50 minutes doing
problems from Chapter 1.
He was not particularly good at
explaining why he did what
he did to solve the problems,
nor did he have any real
patience for people who
wanted explanations.
You know, the why, the what were
the ideas, why would you
do it this way rather than
that way, those weren't
generally part of the course.
So by not making them part of
the course, you're actually
pushing towards their
rote learning.
And that doesn't mean that
there are not all these
interesting questions.
So later on in this selection,
he says, well, actually, you
know, I wonder about all the
names that physicists give.
But there was no space to ask
those questions in class.
He says action/reaction, that's
Newton's third law,
that presupposes a cause and
effect relationship, which
implies duration.
But in physics, actually
action-reaction happen
simultaneously.
So those are the kind of the
questions that he's asking
himself, Eric, the
student, that get
away from rote learning.
But the structure of the
class doesn't encourage
anything like that.
And the only reason he has time
to think about that is
he's not actually trying to
just survive the class.
He's sort of going in as an
experimental student, whereas
the students who are just trying
to survive the class,
if any thoughts like that
occur to them, they
just say, forget it.
No time to think about that. i
have to solve the 10 problems
on the end of Chapter
3 right now.
So those are the causes.
What do you do about it?
Well, there are several
principles of design.
So last time I talked about two
organizational principles,
the signals and systems model
of how to teach a course.
So this was the teaching
equation.
So this is the output,
what students can do.
So you choose that.
You also have to understand
students', students' thinking.
And then you figure out your
teaching given what Given you
want them to be able to do and
how students think, the
misconceptions, how people
learn, visual, by examples,
diagrams like that, how
should I teach?
So that gives you an overall
structure for course design.
The other structure,
which is quite
similar, is backward design.
So backward design, you invert
the normal order.
So the highest level in
backward design is--
that's the and over there.
So this is a hierarchical
structure.
Basically, you choose
your course goals.
You find ways to make
them operational.
So in other words, how would
you measure, for example,
being able to solve Newton's
laws problems in designed
bridges, for example, might
be one of your goals.
Well, you would actually give
them some bridges to design,
things like that.
And then given that you want
them to be able to do that,
what do you do in class?
So this was last time.
That's this time.
And this is next time.
And as I said before, I start
here, just because I find this
is at the right level,
balanced between
concrete and abstract.
So we did that last time.
But now we're here.
How do you choose
course goals?
And that, the paper
by Middlebrook--
so who read Middlebrook's
paper?
A few people.
OK.
So if you haven't read it, I
didn't want to overload you
with reading, but I think it's
also a brilliant paper.
And I know Middlebrook because
he was my teacher at Caltech.
And I took the course that he
describes in the paper.
And he identified a fundamental
problem and a
fundamental solution to it.
In other words, how do
you choose the goals?
And I myself have actually come
to pretty much the same
conclusion through years
of hard experience.
So this is all to answer,
what do you do about it?
Which is, you choose course
goals such that the course
itself will produce transfer.
So let me explain the problem
that Middlebrook identified
and what his solution is.
So his particular class is an
analog circuit design class.
And generally, the way analog
circuit design is taught is
you have a circuit.
And you ask the students
to analyze it.
For example, you give them a
circuit that filters out high
frequency noise, for example,
in an audio recorder in a CD
recording studio.
And you analyze it.
And you see that its
behavior does do--
what is its behavior?
OK.
It throws away high
frequencies.
OK.
So now that's the general
run of the mill.
You'll just get tons and
tons and tons of
problems like that.
And you learn a wave of analysis
that allows you to go
from here to there.
But then what happens when
the student graduates?
What happens is what
Middlebrook calls
a fall off a cliff.
So either they go into graduate
school or into a company.
But either way, what
happens is they're
actually given that.
Somebody says, well, actually,
I need a circuit that doesn't
cost too much but is quite
exact and cuts off all
frequencies beyond 22 kilohertz
and doesn't mess up
the frequencies below
20 kilohertz.
This is actually
a real problem.
That's how you need to
do that to record.
The people who developed the
CD standard had to make
something like this.
So basically you're making a,
quote, "antialias" filter.
So I want that.
Now here, the problem is that
the student has learned
methods of analysis that
cannot be inverted.
For example, one method of
analysis is you have a circuit
and you just simulate
the thing.
You just feed it to your
computer, which does all the
analysis for you.
An analogy for that is if
someone gives you a function
to graph, you can use your
graphing calculator to see
what the graph looks like.
But suppose someone says, well,
I want a graph that
looks like this.
The graphing calculator can't
answer that question.
So they've learned methods
of analysis that are not
invertible.
So they're actually useless,
because the real world problem
is exactly opposite of
the school problem.
The school problem, the
circuit is the start.
In the real world, the
specification is the start.
So to have any hope of going
from there to there--
this is a one-way arrow, it's
like a diet-- you need a
different method.
You need to learn invertible
methods of analysis.
So if you have invertible
methods of analysis, you can
go both ways.
And this problem I think is
central to many, many, many,
many courses, not just to this
particular analog circuit
design course.
So then, what Middlebrook slowly
evolved to was not just
teaching invertible methods of
analysis, but he made those
the foreground of the course.
As he described, "I found in
teaching this stuff for a long
time, I've actually had to put
names and words to ideas for
the students to get
hold of them.
This came about because for a
long time I taught by example.
I used a lot of methods, saying
we're going to look
into the properties of
a certain circuit.
And I would use some shortcut
method or trick that I thought
was a neater way to do it.
And I just showed them this
without actually emphasizing
the method.
That was fine.
But when they did the homework
problems and exams, their
minds just automatically reset
to the old way of doing it.
So that didn't work very well.
And I finally realized I had
to give names to these
things."
And those are the names that
he introduces in the paper.
So those names, some
of those are
specific to analog circuits.
Some are general.
But it's the giving of names
that is the central
[INAUDIBLE].
So you give names to the big
ideas in the course.
And you don't just use them in
passing, but you make them the
focus of the course.
So let's see.
So in answer to what
should the course
goals be, roughly speaking--
OK.
Questions about that, because
it's very different from how
it's normally done?
So if you look, for example, at
a biology course, it might
be organized by, say in cell
biology, organized by the
organ to organelle, the little
system inside the cell.
But those aren't necessarily
transferable to anything
except that particular
subject.
A physics class might be
organized by a whole bunch of
kinematics problems and
dynamics problems.
But a big organizational
principle that is implicit
there but isn't said is that,
well, actually what we're
doing is we're approximating
down to something simple
enough that we can do.
That's an organizational
principle
that you can transfer.
But that's never said.
It's just implicit.
If you look at Chapter 1,
the systems are simpler.
And then Chapter 2,
they get harder.
Maybe they have two dimensions
in them.
In Chapter 5, they have
two particles in them.
In Chapter 7, they have
n particles in them.
So it's this process of
successive complication.
And the beginning part of it,
where we simplified real-world
things into just one particle
moving in one dimension at
constant acceleration, that was
never told to the students.
So the transferable principle
just went straight by them,
because we never made
it explicit.
So you have to, if you ever
want to have any hope of
teaching these ideas, you have
to make them explicit and give
them names.
Giving things names is
absolutely essential to have
any chance of learning them.
And this was known in
all the old legends.
The gods did not want the
mortals to have names for the
gods, because it would give
the mortals too much power
over the gods.
So some gods were
He-who-has-no-name.
And maybe only the high
priest knew the name.
Well, you don't want to
be the high priest.
You want to share the names
with the students.
And that involves a lot and a
lot and a lot of thinking.
That's where most of the work
in course design goes, is
figuring out those main ideas,
those transferable goals and
ways of reasoning that students
can use no matter
what they do.
And then to teach them, you need
to have it from as wide a
set of examples as possible.
So for example, to give you an
illustration, when I teach
dimensional analysis, which is
the idea, and I want them to
be able to use it wherever,
the first example--
I forget whether it's the first
or second. i sort of
flip it around.
The first example is in
economics, because you can
identify a lot of bogus stuff
in economics, because it has
the wrong dimensions.
So I want them to
see it there.
The second example is solid
geometry, volumes of
tetrahedrons and cones
and things.
And then we do sort of a more
standard physics one.
So I want them to see the broad
sweep of this idea so
that the idea comes clear.
So the thing to do is to
identify large ideas.
So these are the--
OK.
So to practice, choose right now
a course in your own mind
that either you are interested
in teaching or teaching now or
would like to teach.
And see if you can come up with
some big ideas for that
course, just to practice what
some big ideas are.
And I will show you as an
example the large ideas for
my-- just to give you an
idea of what they are.
I'll show you the tree for my
approximation course just so
you can see what level these
ideas kind of live at.
So the whole course is designed
around how do you
deal with complex problems and
how do you handle the fact
that the world is
really messy?
And I broke that down into
either you manage it or you
throw it away.
Those are still too high-level
to actually do anything with.
But I wanted to organize
the big ideas as well.
So you can manage it by divide
and conquer reasoning, so
subdividing into smaller
problems.
Or you can make abstractions.
Abstractions is basically the
process of giving names to
things, which is what we're
talking about now.
To throw away complexity, you
can either do it losslessly--
so this is methods of reasoning
that find complexity
that isn't there but look like
it is there and get rid of it.
So symmetry is number one.
And examples of symmetry
reasoning are proportional
reasoning and dimensional
analysis.
So those are all
lossless ways.
They don't actually
cost you anything.
If they work, they make your
life so much easier.
And you haven't thrown
any information away.
Or you can make lossy
compression.
So you can do extreme cases,
look at only the simple cases
of things so you're throwing
out information.
Or you can make spring models.
So even though things aren't--
like chemical bonds, you can
just say, well, they're
just like springs.
So that's a very useful
but lossy way.
Or the final one is
you can lump.
So you can lump changing
processes into one.
For example, a curve, you want
to find the area under the
curve, well, replace it
by one rectangle.
So that general pattern--
those are what I've found are
the most useful ways of
dealing with complex problems.
So these are the big ideas
in that course.
And the whole course is
organized that way.
And I show this tree once a week
usually, just so people
know where they are.
So now, depending on the course,
what stuff you have in
your big ideas will
be different.
But I just want to give you an
idea of what some large ideas,
some structuring
principles are.
And then the course itself is
actually organized Unit 1,
Unit 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
So what I've found is, just like
Middlebrook found, that
not only do you have to give
names to the things, but I
found that I had to actually
organize the course around
them, rather than organizing
them around the topics that
they apply to, if I really
wanted the techniques, the
ways of reasoning,
to transfer.
OK.
So questions about what these
large ideas, these reasoning
principles, are?
What kind of things
to look for?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What's the topic
of the course?
PROFESSOR: The course
is called The Art of
Approximation in Science
and Engineering.
So actually, it's carte blanche
to talk about anything.
So that's why these are probably
higher-level objects
than in most courses which
will be narrower.
But even there, like for example
in physics, in the
Intro Physics, one of the
core ideas is successive
approximation.
And that's not brought
out normally.
But you could bring it out.
You could say, look, we're
using successive
approximation again.
Or here's the structure of the
course, so that it's plain for
the student.
Does that help?
OK.
So pick that course
in your mind.
And talk to your neighbor.
And see if you come up with,
say, two or three large ideas.
And now what we're going to do
is we're going to put them on
the board, the reason being that
you'll find that people's
big ideas and large ideas from
other courses you'll be able
to use in your course,
not every single
one, but many of them.
That's almost by definition what
makes something a large
idea, that it's not just
limited to that course.
So it helps to see what
other people's are.
So I'll make some space on the
board to draw those up.
So I'll give you a chance to
develop your list farther in
the homework.
Oh, I should say something about
the homework, which is
that you guys are all
grad students, or
almost all of you.
You're all taking the
course for fun.
It's kind of pointless of me to
police whether you're doing
stuff or not.
But all the same, I will give
you an assignment to do--
and I'll just trust that
you'll do it--
which is to work with each other
on making large ideas
for a course and then figuring
out examples for those large
ideas, so basically a sketch
of a course design And the
reason to do this, starting now
and also later, is that
basically that is the hardest
work of course design.
Once you've done that,
everything else sort of flows.
The syllabus writing, all
that stuff, just flows.
But if you haven't done
this, you're just
kind of spinning around.
And you don't actually know
what you're doing.
It's really hard to actually
figure out how you should
start and what you should do.
So, big ideas.
Any big idea in any course?
AUDIENCE: Separation of scale.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Separation of scale, so that
behavior at one scale and
another scale, you can often
separate them and analyze them
differently and without
interfering with each other.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
past problems and then
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Separation of scale.
So for example, I've seen that
done in neurobiology.
It's done in physics
all the time.
So in neurobiology, the calcium
flux, the calcium
concentration changes slowly,
so you do the calcium
concentration separate from,
say, the sodium and the
potassium, which is done with
the action potential spikes.
So separation scales, very
important principle across
many fields.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Equilibrium.
PROFESSOR: Equilibrium.
Is that right?
So equilibrium, right away you
can see if you really want
students to understand the value
of equilibrium, you have
a whole set of examples
to use, to steal from.
You can use chemistry,
physics, mechanical
engineering.
And they all have slightly
different senses to
equilibrium, statistical
mechanics.
But there's some core idea
that's the same.
And so it also is an argument
for team teaching, or actually
talking to colleagues from
different fields to steal
examples from them.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I don't know how
to describe this, but it
describes a process which we all
do research, and that is
how to deal with scientific
problems.
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So identifying a scientific
question and how to start
studying it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Identifying and studying.
Right.
And there's many things that are
common across many fields.
different in each field.
And you can actually have
a very fruitful--
I could imagine a really
fruitful interesting--
you could almost teach a
whole class on this.
Actually, that sounds
kind of fun.
You could teach a history of
science class on scientific
questions that were identified,
how they were
studied, what principles
still are done today.
You could have people read
papers from across many fields
and read the intro and see
how they would study that
question, see what questions
there are.
Yes.
Sharon.
AUDIENCE: Resonance.
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
PROFESSOR: Resonance.
Right.
Resonance you can have
a field day with.
It's in electric circuits.
It's in mechanical systems,
the earth-moon system, the
tides are driven almost
on resonance by the
moon and the sun.
Resonance is everywhere.
It's in mechanical systems.
There's beautiful films
you can show of the
Tacoma Narrows Bridge.
I think the London Millennium
Footbridge as
well got hit by resonance.
So resonance, another very
transferable idea.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How to develop
3D models.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So how to build models.
Right.
And that's something
that there are
general patterns to it.
And some of it's specific
to a particular course.
But there are general
patterns.
And that's something the
students can use no matter
what they do later.
Whenever you go to
a new field--
so there's a Nobel
Prize winner at
Harvard, Walter Gilbert.
So he's worked in I think
chemistry, physics, and
biology, many different
fields.
And he said, oh, yeah.
Whenever you go to a new field,
there's only a few key
ideas in that new field.
And the hard work is figuring
out what those are.
But that's what you
have to do.
So that is one of the
transferable skills as well.
Others?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Problem solving
requires communication.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So communication.
Right.
If you can't communicate, you
haven't solved the problem,
which reminds me of my Caltech
students, when I
had them keep a journal.
And then I told them I wanted
them to explain--
the journal they liked.
But then I said, on the
homeworks, I want you to
explain your reasoning
so that it reads.
It's not just hence and
thus and therefore.
And they said, well, why
we have to do that?
We're physics students.
I said, well, later on, you're
going to have to communicate
your answers to someone.
They said, oh, we'll just hire
someone who does that.
So then I said to them, "well,
how are you going to explain
it to that person?
How will they know?" I said, "oh
you're going--" "oh, I'll
explain it to them." I said,
"oh, so you are explaining
something?"
They said "oh, no." Somebody
said, "oh, well, actually that
person will understand it
already." So then I said to
them, "well, so that person
understands it already and can
communicate it.
And you just understand it.
Who are people going
to turn? "
So only then did they agree that
it was a good thing to
actually write problem sets
so they could communicate.
So that's something you
can teach in any
field and across fields.
You could look at scientific
writing.
You could look at writing
scientific papers.
You can look at giving
presentations.
Doing it on problem sets so they
communicate, you can have
students exchange problem
sets with each other.
If they can't understand the
other problem set, clearly it
wasn't communicated.
Other transferable ideas?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Coordinates.
PROFESSOR: Coordinates.
Yes.
So coordinates and--
it's also fun to make this
kind of list, because you
start to see commonalities
and they start to
suggest other ones.
So when you say coordinates,
I also think, oh, yeah.
That's a general example
of representations.
So there's different--
this is probably what you
meant is coordinate
representations, what you
were thinking of.
But you can also think of the
general idea of choosing good
representations for solving
particular problems.
Like for some problems,
a symbolic
representation may be right.
And some, there's a pictorial
representation.
You want to use in circuits,
the time domain
representation, or the
frequency domain
representation.
So coordinates, I'll put dot,
dot, dot, to say that almost
leads to the next one, which is
representation in general.
Others?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Symmetry.
PROFESSOR: Symmetry.
Yes.
Symmetry, incredibly powerful.
Adrian, and then you're next.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Then you have
approximation [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So linearization.
And that is of course
also huge.
I mean, symmetry is used
in almost every field.
Linearization, basically
you can't do
anything that's nonlinear.
So every field does
linearization.
So that core idea would be
beautiful to convey that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Error.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Errors .
How do you deal with errors?
There are common principles,
probability theory,
statistics, that deal with
errors in any field.
What are those?
Well, that's what you want to
understand so you can move to
any other field.
I'll put a dot, dot here, so
symmetry, another one that's
related to symmetry
is conservation.
Noether's theorem is that
every conservation law
corresponds to a symmetry
and vice versa.
I think I've stated
that correctly.
But they flow from each other.
So actually I do conservation
here as part of symmetry.
So let me stop the list
right there, just to
say that right away--
so let me put the other one
which I talked about before,
which is successive
approximation, that you don't
want to solve a hard problem
all at once.
It's sort of like divide
and conquer.
But you want to try to solve it
approximately and then less
approximately, then less less
approximately, so you get
closer and closer, as
close as you need.
That's a general principle of
engineering design as well.
So these, just to show you
that all of a sudden you
thought of a whole bunch
of examples.
And probably you can use that
in any course you take.
So now you all have like 11.
Right now I'm not saying
you have to use
all 11 in your course.
But you can start to restructure
courses around
those ideas and make them
explicit and choose which you
think are the most important in
your field in the ways of
thinking and illustrate them
with things from your field
but nearby as well.
So this evening I'll post
a reading for next week.
And I'll post a short assignment
basically to
continue this line of thinking,
just to give you
some more practice
in course design,
fleshing it out farther.
But what you've done is the key
step, the hardest step to
course design.
So if you could fill out
the question sheet,
as always very helpful.
And also there was a
question before.
Could I make sure to list
on the website things I
mentioned in class?
Yes.
I should do that.
So if I could request people to,
if you have in your notes
any of the books that I
mentioned in class but didn't
put on the website, if you could
email me those, I will
put them on the website.
So as a sort of divide and
conquer approach, I'm sure
actually collectively you
have all of them.
OK.
So just when you're done, you
can put the sheets up here.
And then outside of that door,
we'll have office hours as
usual so that the next class
doesn't get delayed by us
being in here.